[Music]
while at malacca
i learned some great news from some
portuguese merchants
very trustworthy people they spoke to me
of certain great islands discovered some
time ago
they are called the islands of japan
our holy faith they say could there be
more profitably propagated than in any
other part of the indies
because the japanese are very desirous
of being instructed
which our gentiles of india are not
what i feel in my soul makes me think
that i
or another of the company will go to
japan before two years
although the voyage is full of perils
[Music]
father alexander brought a more from the
indies with him
he was as black as the ethiopians of
guinea with a native of mozambique
those who are properly termed kaffirs
and who live
near the cape of good hope as soon as he
arrived at the church
the whole city turned out to view him
[Music]
when we left the city of sakai a myriad
of people were waiting in the streets to
see the extremely tall
father visitor and the colour of the
black man we had with us
even though sakai is a free city a huge
number of the population and warriors
were gathered along the narrow street
through which we were passing and some
of the shops were damaged but
nobody complained our procession leaving
sakai was
35 pack horses around 30 to 40 baggage
carriers
and about the same number of us riding
horseback even the black man frequently
mounted up
we were welcomed by the people lining
the roads as well as by a large number
of
mounted warriors and many more warriors
accompanied our convoy
supplying us with horses as needed
on monday a large number of people were
in kyoto
for nobunaga's festival
[Music]
when they saw the black man they started
to make lots of noise
we heard the sounds of people wounded by
stones
and others dying they were breaking down
the doors and it was only with some
difficulty
that our guards could repel them
everyone agreed
that if we displayed the man we could
earn eight to ten thousand crusados
in a short time nobunaga expressed a
great desire to see him
so father organo took him they made a
great fuss of him and threw him a party
nobunaga was unable to believe that his
color was natural
so made him strip from the waist up he
became convinced that the colour was not
artificial
and sent for his sons who treated him
with extraordinary grace
nobunaga's nephew who is now the
governor of osaka
gave him 10 000 boxes of copper coins
we have done great work by this
this video is sponsored by magellan tv
the documentary streaming service
so quick update from coco after having
obtained her phd from
catbridge university in ancient chinese
studies
she's now got a new challenge the
entirety of time
itself so her and my documentary
recommendation this week
is when will time end a fascinating
exploration of how much time the
universe has left and just one example
of the wide variety of documentaries
magellan has here at voices of the past
we give you the raw source without
comment
magellan is a great choice if you want
more context
it has the widest range of history
content available anywhere among lots of
other genres
many available in high quality 4k click
on the link in the description
for an exclusive month-long free trial
for voices of the past viewers
thanks
on the 23rd of the second month a
black lad came from the christian
country
he appeared to be 26 or 27 years old
black over his whole body just like an
ox
this man looked robust and had a good
demeanor
what is more his formidable strength
surpassed that of ten men
the jesuit fathers brought him along by
way of paying respects to nobunaga
the black man called yasuke was given a
stipend a
private residence etc and was given a
short sword
with a decorative sheath he is sometimes
seen
in the role of weapon bearer
[Music]
a black man accompanied the father
visitor and as one had never been seen
in the capital before
it caused great surprise among the
people and many came to see him
for themselves nobunaga was also
intrigued
for as it was his first time to see a
black person in the flesh
he was not easily convinced that his
skin was not in fact
died and would often go to see him as he
understood some japanese
nobunaga never tired of talking to him
and as he was also strong and
entertaining he pleased nobunaga and
gained his patronage
and nobunaga had someone accompany him
and take him around the city
there were even people who said nobunaga
would make him
tono or lord
oda nobunaga the king of owari who would
be around 37 years old is
tool of stature lean sparsely bearded
with
extremely solderous voice given to
military exercises
indefatigable inclined to works of
justice and compassion
arrogant a great lover of honor very
secretive in his decisions
a master of stratagems hardly or not at
all mindful of the reprimands or advice
of his subordinates
and is feared and venerated by
all to the highest degree he doesn't
drink wine in his
busk and his manners looks down upon all
the other kings and princes of japan
and speaks to them with disdain as if to
his inferiors
[Music]
as our church in miyako is situated only
a street away from the place where
nobunaga was staying
some christians came just as i was
vesting to say in early mass
and told me to wait because there was a
commotion in front of the place
and that it seemed to be something
serious as fighting had broken out there
we at once began to hear musket shots
and see
flames after this another report came
and we learned that it had not been a
brawl but that akechi
had turned traitor and enemy of nobunaga
and had him surrounded when akechi's men
reached the palace gates
they once entered as nobody was there to
resist them because there had been no
suspicion of this treachery
nobunaga had just washed his hands and
face and was drying himself with a towel
when they found him and forthwith shot
him in the side with an arrow
pulling the arrow out he came out
carrying a naginata
a weapon with a long blade made after
the fashion of a scythe he fought for
some time
but after receiving a shot in the arm he
retreated
into his chamber and shut the doors
we were most concerned for the black man
that father visitor had left with
nobunaga
in no time at all the enemy surrounded
the hanaji
the temple where lord nobunaga was
staying and came
bursting in from all four sides
at first both nobunaga and his pages
thought that a passing quarrel had
broken out among the lower orders
but nothing could have been further from
the truth the enemy raised the battle
cry
and blasted nobunaga's residential
quarters with their guns
this is treason nombonaga stated whose
plot is it
they look like akechi's men moriran
replied
nobunaga's response was what's done
is done
attacking relentlessly akechi's men
quickly forced their way into nobunaga's
residence
nobunaga's guards at the front hall fell
back to join forces with the defenders
of his personal quarters
nobunaga's pages went at the enemy again
and again and all were killed in battle
nobunaga first grabbed his bow but when
he had let fly two or three times
the string broke its time apparently
having come as well
he continued the fight with a spear but
suffered a spear wound to his elbow and
retreated
up to that point his women had remained
by him but now
he ordered them get out hurry they won't
harm women
once the women had been chased away he
had his personal quarters set on fire
and soon the entire building was aflame
not wanting anyone to see his final
moments
it would seem nobunaga retired deep into
his residence
and shut the door of a utility room from
the inside
we were most concerned for the black man
that father visitor had left with
nobunaga
after nobunaga was killed he went to the
castle of the prince
nobunaga's son nobutada and fought hard
a retainer of akechi came to him and
asked for his sword
which he then surrendered the retainer
of akichi
asked him what to do with the black man
and he responded that he was a beast who
did not know anything
nor he was japanese so he should not be
killed but taken to the church of the
priests of india
we calmed him down and gave thanks to
god
for delivering him
[Music]
the edicts of toyotomi hideyoshi
japan is the country of gods but has
been receiving
false teachings from christian countries
this cannot be tolerated any further
the missionaries approach people in
provinces and districts to make them
their followers
and let them destroy shrines and temples
this is an unheard of outrage
when a vassal receives a province a
district a village or another form of
thief
he must consider it as a property
entrusted to him
on a temporary basis he must follow the
laws of this country
and abide by their intent however some
vassals illegally commend part of their
thiefs
to the church this is a culpable offense
the padres by their special knowledge in
the sciences and medicine
feel that they can at will entice people
to become their believers
in doing so they commit the illegal act
of destroying the teachings of
buddha prevailing in japan these padres
cannot be permitted to remain in japan
they must prepare to leave the country
within 20 days
of the issuance of this notice
you